yeah yeah I love it I love you all right
all right that's it calm down calm down
all right so let's admit America is a
very lucky country we got Chick-fil-A we
got Shannon bream I'm not sure which one
is more
religious and you know what else we've
got two big oceans three if you count
Canada but but the Atlantic and Pacific
are like giant Moes against many of the
world's worst people you know Kim
Jong-un Iran
Abba let's call it ocean privilege eight
years ago a brilliant and handsome
commentator who many hoped would become
president for Life called it just that
our ocean privilege coupled with a
society immersed in a leisur driven coma
makes defending our exceptionalism
against evil so old this lucky
complacency found in our our media our
government and our campus has blossomed
into a potent disdain for America's good
well thank you Captain
yummy you know the camera loves my face
the same way Joy Bayard loves a tub a
hot
lard now that was from eight years ago
and unlike Joe Biden that's aged like a
fine wine not an already cut
avocado but with a few awful exceptions
like 9/11 and Pearl Harbor and the Dave
Matthews Band America's privilege has
kept the world at Bay however now it's
allowed generations of idiots to get
softer than Jerry nadler's jogging
bra having that buffer allowed us to
forget how tough it was to become the
world's leading Nation but three things
are shrinking those oceans and we better
wake up to it guess what none of them
are climate change or white supremacy
the first is social media which
collapses borders between us and foreign
radical ideologies it's not just about
eating Tide Pods and creepy fans sharing
pictures of my feet though I appreciate
it it's a toxic mind virus that has one
side deeming the other as subhuman now
before social media when some of the
world's major crazies decided to spread
their views here they had to get on a
boat now they just get on Facebook or
get retweeted by John
cusac the Nazis tried it in the 1930s
with something called the German
American Bund thankfully this pro-nazi
agenda went over about as well as Dylan
Mulaney doing hammer
curls in the 1950s the Soviets tried to
create what Stalin called useful idiots
here by funding the Communist Party of
America ABC does the same thing now by
funding these
idiots today however social media
reaches our most vulnerable our young
and stupid who end up believing that
some of the worst ideas in the world
will make the world better many end up
voting for the worst kind of idiots
leading to open borders and an end to
cash bail and repeat criminals running
the streets there's little we can do to
stop it and so it leads to the second
thing shrinking our ocean privilege the
Homegrown hate we see now on our streets
they see us as oppressors while
condemning the freedoms that let them
Proclaim our destruction this was on
full display in the People's Republic of
Brooklyn over the weekend when a large
pramas crowd rioted against the NYPD
this isn't fervent defense of a people
it's a fervent attack on us while
defending ghouls who beheaded babies and
what Brave protesters huh they want to
fight with cops who know they will be
restrained but I don't see too many
riers buying tickets to fight in Gaza
they're probably worried one of their
own will try to hijack the plane the
same goes for those useful idiots
drawing SWAT stickers on campus
buildings and demanding that Palestine
be free from The River To The Sea I
guess they mean the Hudson to the
Atlantic but thanks to their Marxist
College educations they probably can't
find either on a map but in other words
wipe out Israel and in time America
while we stay here comfortable at
Harvard of course it's not just social
media spreading this according to a
Gallop poll from earlier this year Dems
now support the Palestinians over Israel
49 to 38% and by looking at how the
media Embraces hoaxes like the hospital
bombing expect that number to be higher
than hunter in a wh
house the media talks a lot about hate
speech but somehow don't see the own
role in Nazi insignias on campus Soviet
style socialism from the squad and now
Islam terrorism from Hamas and of course
the last thing shrinking our ocean
privilege is Biden's border which adds
opportunities for importing foreign born
radicals he's turned what's left of this
country into a terror magnet they're
flocking to this country like they saw
an online ad for a promiscuous
sheep it's as if we just haven't created
enough radical haters ourselves for the
academic activist machine the latest
number is 169 illegal immigrants stopped
at the southern border who were on the
terror watch list Which is higher than
the last six years combined apparently
under Biden everything bad goes up gas
prices food prices War inflation crime
Pelosi's
eyebrows so as we attempt to Tamp down
terrorism on the other side of the world
we're importing it here I guess it's
just a lot easier to be a terrorist here
instead of prison you get tenure but
locally growing our Terror makes about
as much sense as capping clean oil wells
in America so we can buy dirty oil from
Venezuela the Unspeakable truth here is
that we are failing the two-step process
to ensure our own Survival three if you
count the way Biden walks through
suicidal ideology and immigration
policies we're going from the leading
Bastion of freedom and Power in the
world to just another country led by an
out of touch old man an old man
listening to naive advisers who Shrunk
the Rio Grand shrunk this strategic oil
reserve and are now shrinking two entire
oceans what is it with oceans and
shrinkage anyway you know between the
media the Dems Biden and the rest of our
woke Geniuses I'm not sure two oceans is
enough maybe elon's right about hitting
up a new planet if America was the last
hope and it's fading Mars is looking
pretty good right about
now what an let's welcome tonight's
guest he was voted EST man alive by
Soldier of Fortune Magazine Fox and
Friends Weekend co-host Pete
hexit he's a shining example of what
people can achieve without Talent host
of one nation and the Brian kilme radio
show Brian
kilme her NBA interviews are like a Joe
Biden press conference focused on men
who dribble host of The Hoop chat Emily
Austin and he's a comedian's comedian as
opposed to an audience's comedian writer
and comedian Joe
deito Brian kill me you know our border
is wide open to terrorists and yet
somehow you stay how is life so unfair
um thanks for the question exactly like
I predicted and I blame Joe for my intro
I'm not going to blame you all right uh
couple of things do I have to answer
that question yeah you can answer
whatever you want I'm Italian America
Italian Irish aren't sneaking across the
border they're signing the guest book
over at Ellis Island they still come
there they don't know it's a museum uh
and we come in we come out uh it's okay
uh that was the good old days when we
used to say okay go get a job if you
can't uh get a job you can leave the
ship is still out there for you we've
changed gears entirely Pete he said did
something on Fox Nation about that it's
available now you can download it Fox
Nation is a great app uh but more on
that later uh there will be no more on
that later how dare you I just I looked
at that Brooklyn story yeah and I'm
saying to myself what's going on in
Brooklyn that's a problem remember the
good old days when it used to be the mob
running Brooklyn right and the cops
would know if we just leave them alone
they're going to go somewhere else and
if they break the law we'll we'll know
where to find them because we have
somebody in the inside now all of a
sudden these Palestinians start rising
up taking over and refus to get out of
the street and that to me is absolutely
insane it is an anti-American approach
to uh immigration and it adds to the big
story and that Israel is our number one
Ally if you're not taking down a statue
about our history you're jumping down
the throat of one of our allies well you
just coming out against the country I
don't understand it's this seems to be
opposite day for the last 10 years yeah
I think I explained it to you in my
monologue apparently you weren't
listening it's the death of ocean
privilege Mr kill me you mean that
brilliant guy from the 1980s he came up
with I I look younger now than I did
then you really do yeah thank you it's
okay you can
applaud they're reporting moisturizer
yes it's true so Pete what do you make
about that do you think that we've been
pretty lucky having these oceans oh for
sure yeah it insulated us from a lot of
things for a very long time we were able
to decide what terrain we would go to it
went all the way through our generation
of wars in Iraq and Afghanistan you're
fighting on someone else's soil and at
I've thought a lot about this while we
were doing that we lost our own country
right and we're in unchartered territory
trying to keep a republic that is
training and teaching up the Next
Generation to hate the premise of their
country and then undermining every
institution that maintained it ripping
God out of everything ripping our own
history out of everything where the true
foundational ideas came from and then we
wonder why the world is upside down and
I think that's why there's such an
unsettling feeling for so many because
there's nowhere else to sail to yes it's
it's us or nobody and Israel's on the
frontier of this fight because of where
where they are geographically and we're
we're gutting ourselves in the process
and so we can't stand this is why all
these guys are obsessed uh with the
Roman Empire right online everybody's
like what because they they they're
going how did the Roman Empire decline
well you're watching it right now
instead of bread and circuses it's carbs
and Tick Tock Emily is it kind of
frightening to see what's going on on
these campuses oh my God yeah I mean it
wasn't so different I want to tell you
now it's just being put in the public
eye but College campuses have been a
breeding ground for communism first and
foremost but secondly it's a cafe Haven
for Jew hatred you know not too long ago
I was in college and this star of David
never came off and my professor would
say oh you know you're only on camera
cuz you're a young blonde Jew and I'm
like hell yeah absolutely but he would
say he tried he tried to say in an
insulting way but the problem is free
speech is protected and I'm a huge
proponent and say what you got to say
but face the consequences and there are
are no consequences on college campuses
unless you say something that's like
against wokeism and that's the problem
and that's why college students are
freaking morons today because their
professors are you know I'm really
careful not to misgender the
terrorists important yeah because they
have feelings uh Joe you know some say
that your comedy Act is like War um
because I take no prisoners no you
that's true that's true uh what is your
take on the the decline of America's
power well uh to prepare I've been
reading uh Revelation for
dummies for world I'm looking at this I
don't understand what the the nuances
people are looking for there's two
things that I look for in politics that
if one side has swastikas I go for the
other side yes you know I I find the
swasti on the big red flag it raises a
lot of red flags yes yeah and the other
thing is if someone says we want to kill
you you're better off believing them
listening to them and and you know look
at the example of the the fake bombing
of the hospital the way that the media
was so quick to jump on that as if they
couldn't believe that it could be
anything else that oh it was from
Islamic Jihad are you sure you sure it
wasn't Presbyterian Jihad you sure it
wasn't uh Jehovah's Witness Jihad with
the bomb knocks on the door they found a
red hat at the
hospital yeah so it's um it's I don't
know I don't know what the solution is
to what we're seeing happening in our
own country now that we our young people
so indoctrinated to hate this country
that welcomes people and you know I come
from a family of immigrants and I
believe in the American dream my
grandfather came here from Italy with 10
cents in his pocket and a 100 years
later I've doubled
[Laughter]
that
yeah he's no longer with us right in
this room right now no he would be over
but he passed on he's passed on probably
good that he doesn't see what you're
doing
now oh that hurts you want on Gutfeld
what are you thinking what you all right
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else